[Music]
let me start by saying congrats on the
movie i thought
rather man was so well done and that's
really all i have today we'll call it
see you i love it
have a good one peace secondhand may 7.
exactly uh because i have a few minutes
with you um
i i ask a lot of you know a whole bunch
of different kind of questions so let's
just jump on
in um what tv series would you love to
guest star on
oh that's a good one um
i don't know man i i uh i loved wanda
vision
recently i would have loved to have like
you know
gone into her world you know no knowing
the backstory of what she created
and how people in there were being
manipulated by her it would have been
interesting to see how
you know my character or whatever that
would have been
would have fit into her story i thought
it was brilliant
i loved that show i loved it um what
movie or movies do you think you've seen
the most
definitely rocky movies um
i i i feel like i learned
the whole uh action genre
from watching rocky and then going on to
rambo
and then all the other movies that
sylvester stallone did in that era
and then after that i graduated to
arnold schwarzenegger
and you know wait hold on
there you go baby that's it you know
they were they were like my
my escapism when i was a kid
you know and uh and now i get to do that
for other kids so it's dope
when did you feel like you made it as an
actor where like you could pay
rent doing this as a job
that's a great question i don't think i
ever feel that way man
like uh i think that
our business um forces you to never
feel too secure that this could all
end tomorrow so you really
don't and then you look at other actors
who
did amazing and then now today you're
like
man like so i don't think i ever
felt that way and i i don't think to
this day i still feel that way
i mean i listen i can pay my rent uh
that goes without saying
but do i feel like i made it no
not at all no i understand i've heard
that from a bunch of people
what do you wish someone had told you
earlier in your career
probably to enjoy the journey more i had
such
uh an expectation of being at a certain
level
that the other levels that i was slowly
climbing and achieving i don't think i i
savored them as much as i should have
and i could have
you know so probably enjoy the journey
more and
don't don't worry as much
these are very good very good points um
jumping into wrath of man i think one of
the reasons why the film is so strong
is the script breaks like the typical
narrative structure
jumps around in time introduces
characters
later in the movie that are not in the
movie until then
like it does things that you don't
normally see can you sort of talk about
your reaction
to the script uh that's guy's brain
basically you got a little snapshot of
how guy's brain works
um we got a snapshot of it on set
uh and it was uh
never ceased to to surprise us
every day was different um
but but that's really how he works you
know like
what we thought was the script was
an outline and when we got there on the
day
he would tear it up whatever scenes we
thought we
in lines we thought we knew they were
out the window he'd rewrite
three four new pages of dialogue that
you had to memorize and
and and absorb and go in there new
action sequences no no no this scene
wouldn't play like that he's like who
wrote this and it's like you wrote this
he's like screw that scene this is
what's gonna happen
and then it would be a completely new
scene
um and you're nothing's choreographed
you know you're
you're you're reacting to the changes
and you're screwing up and you're
dropping stuff
and you're running and you're tripping
and falling and the camera just goes
it doesn't stop filming and so
that's that's like the magic behind
guy richie's ultra real action movies
is because you really are in that moment
uh chaotically improvising everything
you do
i also heard that um he does this black
box type
uh thing where before filming he has all
the actors come
together and read through the whole
script i guess it takes like eight hours
you're you know which is very unusual
can you sort of talk about
doing that before you were even filming
so that part
uh i was able to get around that because
yeah i was still shooting the boys and
uh
yeah and i heard about that and they
were like uh maybe he can uh uh
video cam in and i was like tell him i'm
shooting now i really i really was
shooting
um we were actually shooting the season
finale
of the boys when he had this black box
situation
so i wasn't able to participate in that
matter of fact when i wrapped the boys
i literally went to la i had four days
to unpack
repack and then i was on a plane to
london to go start filming
so i want to ask you though were you
nervous when
you couldn't do the black box thing that
like
f i could even recast me because i can't
do this
well i was i was nervous in general
because you never want to feel like
you are not as up to speed and up to
date as everyone else
you know you don't want to feel like
you're coming in down here and you're
unprepared
you know so uh that part uh
did make me feel like ah like i wish i
could participate in that
um but you know in in another sense
uh he never focused on that uh once we
got to london when we got to london it
was just
you know you're going into weapons
training you're going into
uh stunt you know working with the
stunties and you know
working on a little grappling and you
know because every character had
different
action moments and so we all had
different schedules
and uh and it was grueling man i mean
before we got on set like he he put us
through a
a little intensive and uh but it got us
ready for the film
i also think one of the strengths of the
film is the great supporting cast
i love holt jeffrey i mean everybody
that he put in this movie i'm a big fan
of
can you sort of talk about getting to
work with everyone and who ruined the
most takes
i'll tell you uh it was the best feeling
to be
in the green room with all those guys
and um everybody
feel completely at a loss for
what the heck is going on right now like
what did i just
sign up for and what am i filming like i
don't even know what i'm filming right
now
and and that's the energy i i think
that guy likes to get his actors in that
that's where he wants you to be
so that when you're on screen you're not
playing it cool
you know you're playing it almost you're
swimming for your life
you know and and and that's where he
gets that kind of
signature guy richie uh performance
is because you don't have the time to
perfect
the words and the movements you're
literally figuring it out as you go
along
what was your reaction then to seeing
the finished film did you know all the
twists and turns
i obviously don't want you to do
spoilers yeah no i i i didn't
because there were a lot of scenes that
i wasn't in
that again you know like on a guy
ritchie film at least this one
there was a guy walking next to him at
all times
with a laptop slung around his neck
rewriting the scene and as guy
talked he would come up with new
dialogue and the guy's writing and he's
like oh hold on a second hold on a
second i missed that
you know what's that now and and then
they rewrite the scene
and this literally was pretty much every
scene i was a part of
you know so while it feels like
uh it's organized confusion
um you end up
walking out of that scene like man this
was so much better than what originally
was on the page
you know and you're exhausted you're
soaking wet
you're sweating um apart from nerves but
then apart from
additional stuff that happens when when
things aren't rehearsed and practiced
but it just felt more real
it feels the actor and it feels real on
the camera
i think he did that with all the robert
downey jr uh
movies they did together he they work
like that you know constantly rewriting
every day it's it's this process but
before i run out of time with you
obviously you know i'm a huge fan of the
boys
i know you guys have been filming um
where are you in the filming process
uh so i am in toronto um
we are almost we are
almost halfway through uh filming season
three i mean
uh we're we're like let's say
between one-fourth of the way through
and halfway through that's where we're
at
um and uh i can't say much
but i will say that this season is
grounded
uh a lot more in story
um and and i think more so than the last
two seasons
you know like eric crickey i think what
he's doing is every season he's getting
darker and darker and with the addition
of jensen ackles
that allowed him to not only
bring in a character historically who's
pretty dark
but it also makes all of the other
ensemble soups
darker as well so yeah i i'm curious
though
um the first two seasons have definitely
amped up like the first season had blood
the second season had a lot of blood
um how would you compare is one of the
is this season as bloody
as the others or is it different
uh so i'll put it to you this way
i was talking to the makeup um
uh the head makeup artist and she's in
charge
of ordering the blood that's that's her
job one of her many jobs
she told me that all of
season two you remember how much blood
there was in season two
i vividly i don't think they used
um when you when you talk about bulk
i don't think they used over a gallon of
blood
in season two believe it or not uh
season three we're already at three and
a half gallons
of blood so
that should give you a little indication
of where
i am curious though how has uh kovid
impacted the filming process is it um
is it could you sort of talk about how
how does that affect production
we've been very lucky man i mean we
knock on wood
uh have not had any cases um in
our immediate a cast and crew
area we have not
had any stoppages we get tested every
single day we have to wear our masks
constantly whether it's at base camp or
on set everyone has to wear them indoor
or outdoors
just to follow the canadian protocol
mandates and so
uh they they and then even like
on your days off you still get tested
in the event that something were to
happen or someone
gets sick and they have to
re-pull up scenes or reorganize scenes
they want to make sure that everyone is
tested
and able to work in the event that an
emergency were to happen so
they've pretty much crossed every t and
dotted every eye
and uh we've been lucky because up until
now
we haven't had any any problems my last
thing for you because i'm about out of
time
with this season as compared to the
others does eric pull you aside and like
tell you the whole arc
or are you finding it out like script by
script so
in the beginning of the season i don't
know if he does this with all of the
actors but in the beginning of the
season
he and i do talk about mother's milk's
journey
just so that i have an idea of how to
craft where i am
and where i'm going um and how to build
that slowly
um and this season i find that because
he hasn't been here because of covid you
know when you come you got to do a
mandatory 14-day quarantine
and the his ability to come in and out
has been
severely hindered because of all of the
other stuff
um uh it's been a lot more
emails and text messages and i mean
listen
at all hours you know like it could be
eleven o'clock at night
and he'll hit me and i'll respond at
like seven in the morning eastern time
and he'll hit me right back i'm like man
did he ever sleep you know so um
it's it's it's it's extremely
collaborative
uh and uh you still feel his presence
you
you feel that he's got his finger on the
pulse of everything that's going on
um so uh it's fine
it's good on that note i gotta uh stop
i'm just gonna say
really happy for you with uh your work
and rapha man
i it's it's so good um and you know
uh stay safe and i'll talk to you i'm
sure down the road
you as well thank you and may 7th
everybody go see it in theaters if you
can